لدينا كميات احتياطيه ولدينا تخوف من نفاذ
كميات الوقود قلت لك ان جميع اليات
المراكز للدفاع المدني السوري المنتشره في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا هي في العمل الان
منذ اكثر من 70 ساعه على الزلزال العنيف
منذ ان اطلقنا نداءات الاستغاثه حزرنا
ايضا من نفاذ المحروقات
بالاضافه لمعدات البحث والانقاذ قلت لك
والمولدات الكهربائيه بحاجه ايضا للوقود
لكي تستمر الاسراء بعمليات البحث من تحت
الانقاض والاسراع بانتشال او انقاذ مدنيين
لا يزالون احياء حتى اللحظه من تحت
الابنيه المدمره في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
بالنسبه للطرق حميد يعني دائما الانباء
تتحدث بانه هذه الابنيه ايضا انهارت وفي
بعض الطرق مقطوعه كيف تستطيعون ان تتحركوا
في ظل هذه الظروف
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد فرقنا تتوزع في
العمليات التي تقوم بها بالبحث والانقاذ
تؤمن طريق للاخلاء فور وصولها للمكان بفتح
الطرقات وانتشار سيارات الاسعاف فورا في
حال انقذنا اي شخص على قيد الحياه يتم
اسعافه من الطرقات ما زالت مقطوعه ام تم
فتح كل الطرقات التي تاثرت من جراء هذا
الزلزال حتى اللحظه حط اللحظه يوجد طرقات
مقطوعه ويوجد ايضا حارات ضيقه جدا في عده
مناطق من من ريف ادلب الشماليه الغربي
منطقه سلقين الحارات ضيقه جدا هنا الاليات
لا تستطيع الدخول الى المكان الان تعمل
بالمعدات الخفيفه حارم ايضا كذلك الامر
الابنيه
متلاصقه ويوجد بها حارات ضيقه في القناه
تعاني من ذلك الامر لكن فرقنا تحاول قدر
المستطاع تسهيل عمليه البحث والانقاذ
بالوصول لاقرب نقطه يتم فيها اخلاء
المدنيين ليتم اسعافه في جنديرس ايضا
جنديرس ايضا حجم الدمار هائل جدا جدا
لانه هي من اكثر المناطق تضررا يعني
والانباء تصل من هناك بان الوضع فيها يعني
كارثه جدا هل يمكن ان تعطينا معلومات عن
ذلك كارثه بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه جنديرس
تقريبا الدمار فيها
على غالبيه
المنازل والابنيه في جنديرس الان مدمره
ومتصدعه فرقنا حتى اللحظه انتشرت جسامين
اكثر من 380 مدني
الاصابات اكثر من 850 اصابه هذه فقط من
بلده جنديرس العمل صعب جدا
لوجود
لوجود ابنيه كثيره مدمره بشكل كلي رؤوس
ساكنها